we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p today's voicemail
relates to something that has really
become an issue actually over the last
several years and particularly under
donald trump for republicans and the
topic is masculinity let's take a listen
to today's voicemail hey david a real
big fan of the show kinda want to ask
you strange question you condoms
mentioned that trump supporters really
want him to be sort of the alpha in the
room and i guess i just wanted to ask
about that more broadly because if
surprisingly does come up quite a bit
the sort of fixation the fixation mostly
by conservatives on masculinity like
Jesse we Peterson asking you what is a
man you know you're very familiar with
the kind of me to emasculate call people
cook it's funny but it comes up well
what is that do you think it's the sort
of a just a psychological glitch like I
know how likely you are to be disgusted
disgust sensitivity is positively
correlated with conservatism is it
something like that is it something else
and secondly since you've dealt with
quite a bit being in the meteor yourself
how do you manage the people like that
and you even push back is it worth it I
think so the second part is sort of
easier for me which is that if someone's
main critiques of me are that I am an
NPC soy boy beta [ __ ] I'm not
particularly interested in engaging I'm
just not but the first part is very
interesting which is why is there this
hyper focus on masculinity and
identifying who is masculine who is not
masculine I think this actually relates
to you know the part of the obsession
from the write about gay marriage and
transgenderism is religiously based some
of it is simply bigotry but I actually
think that a lot of it is connected to
these preconceived notions and hang-ups
on masculinity that the right has and I
don't know Pat why they're so obsessed
with the degree of masculinity and
who is the most masculine politician and
this is alpha and that's beta but it
could be one one argument would be this
is something they are insecure about and
thus it becomes like a primary narrative
even this sort of guy I know people will
say not all men's rights activists or
right wing but men's rights activism is
more on the right than it is on the left
even that I feel like is based in and
perceived sort of shortcomings that they
perceive about themselves when it comes
to masculinity I don't know what the
source of it is we could say it's
religion we could say it's educational I
don't know but it is an obsession and
isn't it odd or ironic that they all
view Trump as their alpha male to whom
they must be subservient at all times
and I guess Trump really isn't all that
alpha to he did miss that World War 1
ceremony because of rain after all and
dodged the Vietnam War five deferments
all that stuff but yeah I don't think
they have a very even standard when it
comes to that sort of stuff no they
certainly don't and this is a problem
that they have and it's something we
should explore in more detail I'm out of
time great bonus show today hope to talk
to you on the bonus show in mere minutes